l'été est à nos portes et avec lui des
buts la quête du gazon impeccable
souvent obtenue au prix de beaucoup
d'eau et de produits chimiques
mais s'il y avait moyen de faire les
choses autrement de délaisser un peu cet
idéal hérité des jardins aristocratique
des chercheurs des municipalités et de
simples citoyens explore de nouvelles
façons d'aménager nos espaces verts
[Musique]
nous sommes dans un quartier résidentiel
de ce automne en estrie jérémy loubès
s'y est établi avec sa famille en 2018
par souci écologique il a décidé de
laisser pousser le gazon autour de sa
maison
[Musique]
fayyad et ciboure bande on a des gens
qui on a des bouquet de marguerites
incroyable on a d ascq les piannencs je
serai content non quand on a beaucoup de
monarque dans le jardin en fait moi
c'est vraiment une expérimentation jeu
laissait pousser parce que je suis
nouveau face c'est ma première maison
je veux voir un petit peu justement le
comment ça se pose naturellement pour
pouvoir ensuite prendre des décisions
d'aménagement en laissant la nature
s'exprimer il souhaite favoriser le
développement de la biodiversité mais
remise et la tondeuse s'est fait avec un
petit pincement au coeur pour sa
conjointe et lui manque jaffe mois en
fait j'aime bien passer le tracteur à
pelouse c'est un plaisir pour moi
puis la mancha mais il m'a dit on va
arrêter tendre tout le terrain va juste
en deux la partie du milieu où on peut
jouer et j'étais un petit peu déçue ou
début mais finalement je suis dis bah
oui ça fait du sein c'est très polluant
or en temps au moins une fois par
semaine c'est de l'essence c'est de la
pollution sonore
donc en fait à partir du moment où on a
arrêté de tondre le gazon là il ya plein
de fleurs qui sont sortis et moi à
chaque semaine j'avais des bouquets
différents à la maison parce que je
ramassais les fleurs donc c'était
vraiment que les hommes aussi d'avoir
comme la nature qui rentre dans la
maison
ce choix d'aménagement fait le bonheur
du couple mais pas celui du voisinage en
réponse à des plaintes répétées la ville
de sauteur a dû sévir avec un premier
avertissement
le règlement municipal limite à 30 cm la
hauteur du gazon pour les propriétés
privées
ce genre de réglementation n'est pas
rare au québec au cours des dernières
années des litiges entre les citoyens et
leurs municipalités ont défrayé la
manchette
on n'a qu'à penser au cas de
drummondville où les résidents
souhaitait profiter du soleil à l'avant
de leur maison pour y faire pousser des
légumes
une pratique alors interdite
[Musique]
même si certaines villes ont adapté
leurs règlements beaucoup exige encore
une pelouse fraîchement tondues mais à
l'heure où plusieurs s'inquiètent de la
santé de nos écosystèmes
ce choix est-il écologique le problème
c'est pour la plante comme tel mais
plutôt l'entretien et vous est ce que
certaines personnes en ont fait dans le
passé et une mineure de différents corps
aujourd'hui selon statistique canada
environ trois canadiens sur quatre
possède un terrain gazonné
parmi eux près de 20% ont appliqué des
pesticides et 25% des engrais chimiques
en 2018
nous savons que les plus de 2003 au
québec on a des réglementations qui ont
été mis en place pour rester un usage de
certains pesticides sur les gazons donc
ça leur change de mentalité
les citoyens sont beaucoup plus
tolérants avoir des blasons que son
corps ne soit parfait du pont du visuel
dans cette serre laboratoire de
l'université laval de petites touffes de
gazon sont bichonnés guillaume grégoire
et son équipe cherchent à améliorer les
performances biologique et
environnemental du gazon on a un projet
de recherche portant sur les pertes en
éléments nutritifs plus spécifiquement
en azote qui viennent de la
fertilisation des oiseaux ce qu'on veut
faire avec ce projet complète en mesure
de faire des recommandations de dire
elles sont bâties de sol voici tel type
de riz que vous devriez il suffisait à
telle dose pour avoir un gazon qui est
en santé et limiter le potentiel de
contamination des plans d'eau en été une
bonne partie de l'eau traitée par les
municipalités sert à l'arrosage des
pelouses le risque d'entraîner des
particules nocives vers les nappes
phréatiques et les cours d'eau est donc
bien réel et selon le chercheur
l'aménagement d'une pelouse écologique
serait possible
comme toutes les plantes du gazon ça va
séquestrer du co2 sous clans qui est
vraiment excellent pour réduire
l'érosion des sols
donc cessons pelouse durable en fait on
enlève le côté esthétique d'abord on
veut côté utilitaire fonctionnelle une
pelouse en santé mais qui est pour
l'instant à part faire du point de vue
visuel
mais pour avoir une pelouse dit durable
certains devront adapter leurs pratiques
ne pas arroser le gazon jauni et ne pas
le tendre trop court car il faut savoir
que plus l'herbe est longue plus son
système racinaire et développer et
arrive à puiser de l'eau et des éléments
nutritifs dans le sol ce qui veut dire
moins d'arrosage et de fertilisation et
il faudra aussi apprendre à tolérer les
mauvaises herbes
le principe de base dans la menace
toujours la baule plan togo ghana faut
choisir la bonne classe bien adapté aux
conditions climatiques conditions de sol
en fonction des usages qu'on a pour cet
endroit l'eau les jeux sont différents à
6 rebonds parle de gazon ça on n'a pas
besoin d'entretenir toute les gazons de
la même manière dépendamment des
utilisations 600 rapide sinon belle on
voit aussi des graines de gazon par
exemple parce que sont pas vraies les
seuls janvier supported piétinement si
c'est des endroits qui sont copiés de
tri où les rôles sont plus à l'ombre par
exemple les gazons performe pas bien on
va peut-être fusée d'autres d'autres
espèces de couvre-feu qui sont mieux
adaptés cette approche pourrait répondre
à la préoccupation de certaines villes
en matière de gestion des espaces verts
à montréal on s'interroge sur les
pratiques à adopter à l'angle des
boulevards laurentien et gouin un jardin
de fleurs a poussé au milieu du bitume
en 2018
un projet pilote a vu le jour dans
l'arrondissement d'ahuntsic cartierville
l'objectif trouver les meilleurs
couvre-sol alternatif on voulait
augmenter la biodiversité
mais il fallait déterminer quel type de
plante on était pour utiliser passait
pas toutes les plantes qui vont résister
aux conditions de rue pas signaler
celles liées à la sécheresse le
piétinement
c'est vraiment un milieu très difficile
pour les places
pour la ville il fallait trouver une
solution de remplacement au gazon
traditionnel
ici c dans les terres pleins qu'on a
tenté l'expérience
maintenant ce qu'on fait là les
terre-pleins on met un mètre de terre
gronde à fait convient vraiment bonifier
la parlementaire pour les arts les coûts
des autres c'est d'un terre-plein
gazonné c'est énorme c'est extrêmement
demandant il faut arroser le gazon il
faut le temps régulièrement au centre
des quatre voies des plantations
d'herbacées vivaces ont été testés
trèfle luzerne chicorée et weis il y
avait des citoyens qui trouvait qu'il
n'était pas très bien aménagé qui a été
tendu mais finalement ça m'a donné des
résultats pas catastrophique comment
passer au début
ce virage de pratique même les
entreprises de paysagement le constate
on a vraiment
de plus en plus au sein des clients une
divergence d'opinion et on peut
retrouver effectivement le client qui
veut absolument que son gazon soit
parfait le plus fin possible notre n'eut
aucune mauvaise herbe de plus en plus on
voit des clients qui veulent avoir un
résultat beaucoup plus vert
éco-responsable qui est à avoir du
trèfle à l'intérieur du gazon ou de
d'avoir un gazon justement qu un petit
peu plus laisser addition on pourrait
dire quand on est en monoculture il ya
toujours plus d'entretien et puis de
travail arrêt quand qu'on favorise la
biodiversité puis mélanger les espèces
dans notre travail ensemble puis mon
travail à faire
dans les basses-laurentides sylvain
sanscartier a fait un choix clair
intervenir le moins possible et miser
sur la force des plantes
on est à mirabel saint augustin c'est ma
propriété depuis dix ans j'ai tout fait
le terrassement moi même mais c'est sûr
que c'est la nature qui fait le plus
gros travail
il ya des parties du terrain que je
voulais pas touché je les laissais
naturel à son cours qui aurait été
beaucoup beaucoup d'abeilles qui
viennent butiner jeu aucunement tour b c
était seulement de la semence
j'ai fait un mélange de 50 % 13 blanc
est très proche
jenny 1 30% demille puis à peu près 15
20 % de gaz ont la propriété de trêve
c'est que lui fixe l'azoté dans le sol
donc qui va distribuer nutriments à
d'autres plantes
lorsqu'ils tentent leur raison il va
attirer les insectes pollinisateurs et
que c'est très bon pour les abeilles
situer les papillons ces tragédies dans
l urine de chiens ça donc ça joue haut
niveau en plus de ça c'est un répulsif
naturel le conflit vers delà
c'est sûr qu'à la vengeance et dépôts et
un petit peu plus régulièrement pour les
voisins mais en arrière
je peux être plus qu'un mois des fois ça
a coupé dans le fond ça change vraiment
de quoi dans nos vies en bout de ligne
qui soit très très beau ou qu'il soit
parfait ça change pas vraiment grand
chose c'est que ça serait de l'orge est
prise en fait sur sur la perfection que
qu'est ce que l'un terrain devrait être
puis les salles et la nature
[Musique]